I love thinking about leveraging the
laws of likability when giving feedback
because feedback is only effective if
somebody can receive it so you want to
present feedback I say on a silver
platter and not on a garbage can lid you
have to remember it's not about your
communication style
it's about there's the best way to
develop your people is to flex to them
to empower them to adapt your style to
what they need
that's a manager that's a leader that's
a coach so if there's somebody who
really likes direct feedback even if
it's something you're not comfortable
with they will respect and be able to
take it in better if you can just get to
the point if you're somebody who's
really direct and they need a little bit
more tact and diplomacy then you're not
going to need to massage your messaging
so again it can be heard there's a
correlation between the speed at which
somebody receives that feedback and the
importance that they place on it when
you delay feedback you delay the value
you're placing on it so immediacy is
important now not in the exact moment
let them have a moment to breathe but
don't wait more than a day if you can if
it's really crucial you you have that
weekly reading sometimes it will fade
from your memory by that point it
becomes less important to you and to
them so make sure you give that feedback
quickly and specifically don't just say
oh I think it went well tell them why
you thought it went well
what specifically they did that you
thought went well and then challenge
them with the next opportunity give them
something to keep growing from so if you
think about the most important law of
likeability it's the law of curiosity
and I have a model that you can walk
through any challenging or feedback
conversation that will leverage these
laws of likeability starting with
curiosity curiosity creates connections
and connection is important in these
conversations because when you're
receiving feedback you're considering
your source and when you don't value
trust or like the source then you might
not be really willing to take that
information in so the model is four
parts ask elaborate empower collaborate
ask is going to leverage that low of
curiosity start with a question and make
sure that question is open-ended it's
not you know do you think that went well
which is implying that you don't think
that went well instead you ask how do
you think it went what do you think went
well what do you think could have gone
better and get them talking that's the
key to opening up a feedback
conversation is to get the information
from them it actually makes it easier on
you as a manager because you see where
they're at what they already know
they're bringing information in the room
and you can determine oh we're about on
the same page or we have completely
different views of the situation and
that will help kind of tweak the
information that you need to bring it to
the room oftentimes people are much
harder on themselves than you'll ever be
on them the next love likability is the
most important thing you have to listen
so listen for the understanding listen
for the concern listen for a different
view and interpretation of the situation
because we know we're coming in with a
belief about what happened we need to
try to check that assumption at the door
and listen for other possibilities other
narratives alright so we've asked we've
listened now it's your turn as the
manager ask elaborate this is your
chance to add information that you might
have heard collected from other sources
be additive don't say well I heard
instead you'll say additionally I
received information from so-and-so and
this and that and you're bringing in
that information my perspective of and
it could be elevating them feedback
isn't always negative you don't have to
brace them and you don't have to brace
yourself feedback is simply information
and it's information that you want to
make somebody able to use and put into
action so that is the first half of the
conversation before you move on to the
second half what I want you to think
about our root causes what are the root
causes and the reasons that it went so
well what are the root causes and the
reasons that it didn't go so well is
there something that's underlying that
can help us in the second half of this
conversation where we're looking for the
solutions
did you not have training did you not
have authority did you not have budget
what happened let's evaluate that before
we move on now you're gonna throw back
to the other person you're going to
empower them get them to throw the ideas
out of what they think the next step
should be so what would you do
differently next time or how do you
think we can move forward from here are
great questions to start the empower
phase as we empower them and bring those
ideas you have to be very careful at
that last stage of the conversation
where you're collaborating because as
the manager as the leader when you put
your idea out there they're just gonna
defer so build off of their ideas I love
that I think in addition you could also
do this or maybe even switch the order
what do you think the collaboration
isn't a dictation the collaboration is
the exchange now another key thing that
can happen in that last phase of the
feedback especially when things might
not have gone the way that you wanted is
to leverage the law of similarity by
sharing experience that you went through
that might be similar to what they're
experiencing you create a teachable
moment you build trust when you're
vulnerable with your employees you
actually increase your credibility
so remember vulnerability is not about
weakness
it's about openness so share the story
of how when things didn't go so well for
you what you did what you learned how it
went and let them know it's okay we all
make mistakes that we can still get to
the positions that you're in and the
last thing to remember is the law of
likeability called mood memory because
if they walk away from that conversation
not feeling good they're going to want
to throw out all of the information that
they've received so mood memory is that
people remember more how you make them
feel than anything that you said so
ensure that you are being
action-oriented feedback is not about
berating somebody or punishing you focus
on the past to make a plan for the
future
that's feedback
[Music]